[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardiña y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso oriente El magacín
quincenal de France 24 en el que les
acercamos las historias de medio oriente
América Latina Esto es lo que veremos
hoy
Irán reabrirá su embajada en Arabia
Saudita siete años después del cierre
debido a una ruptura diplomática el
restablecimiento de las relaciones entre
Teherán y riath se logró con la
mediación de China y se materializará en
un período menor a dos meses tenemos
análisis
y Kuwait acudió a las urnas en unas
elecciones anticipadas las terceras en
los últimos 3 años con la esperanza de
salir del estancamiento la oposición
mantuvo la mayoría de los escaños en el
parlamento y tan solo una mujer fue
elegida como miembro de la asamblea
nacional en el país del Golfo
los residentes de la comunidad Palestina
ain samiya en la cisjordania ocupada se
han visto forzados al desplazamiento por
los ataques de colonos israelíes
contamos la historia personal del líder
de esta comunidad Palestina que relata
Cómo fue la expulsión de su tierra
iniciamos con el restablecimiento de las
misiones diplomáticas iraníes en Arabia
Saudita una señal de acercamiento entre
dos países con la reapertura de la
embajada de Teherán en riat después de
siete años de puerta cerradas Esto
ocurrió debido a unas que las turbas
yraníes asaltaron instalaciones
diplomáticas sauditas en Irán después de
que esto se ejecutarán a 49 personas
entre ellas un destacado clérigoxiiita
todo esto en el año 2016 analizamos este
tema con site chaya politólogo y
especialista en medio oriente Muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros en France
24 site lo primero que significa este
restablecimiento de las relaciones entre
estas dos grandes potencias de medio
oriente Y por qué ahora qué interés
tiene cada parte
bien Esto no significa de una manera que
vamos a evitar
conflictos a futuro entre uno y otro
estado es decir vamos a seguir
presenciando fricciones entre ambos
estados pero ahora encausadas encausadas
en no los carriles diplomáticos eso es
lo que estamos viendo no Entonces es
imposible pensar una región como el
medio oriente sin los conflictos
cotidianos que tiene Pero bueno la
existencia de canales existentes la
existencia de canales abiertos entre
estas ambas potencias regionales rivales
van a permitir que los problemas que
vayan surgiendo se resuelvan de manera
mucho más ágil verdad Y también sabemos
que Beijing está en el medio de estas
conversaciones que está tratando de
hacer china en medio oriente está
tomando el espacio de Estados Unidos en
un momento de disminución de su
presencia allí
Beijing ha realizado en en los últimos
años
una tarea
silenciosa una tarea paciente que
finalmente tuvo su corolario me parece
como hito en la diplomacia regional a
través de
auspiciar no el a través del auspicio de
estas de estas conversaciones yo creo
que principalmente lo que está buscando
china en esto coinciden conmigo los
principales analistas que
que han hablado sobre esta cuestión es
asegurar asegurar la provisión constante
de crudo a su país no y esto lo ha
llevado a justamente a encarar una
gestión de este tipo que ha sido que ha
sido exitosa no zaid y en su opinión
Cuáles son las consecuencias de esta
entrada de china en la región
yo no creo que china termine siendo un
gran jugador en la región que intervenga
directamente como lo hemos visto que ha
hecho Estados Unidos en los años
anteriores creo que china ha observado y
ha visto lo golpeado que ha salido
Estados Unidos de la región China tiene
fundamentalmente intereses económicos es
decir la posibilidad de que sus
productos puedan atravesar la región en
paz el flujo de crudo se asegure no y en
todo esto va a llevar adelante los
canales que tenga que llevar pero por lo
que hemos visto hasta ahora tiene la
intención de dar el protagonismo a Irán
y Arabia Saudita en las gestiones que
deseen llevar adelante no creo que
busque un primer lugar un protagonismo
excesivo como no sé el que vimos por
parte de Estados Unidos de los 70
básicamente hasta hasta esta última
década
de hecho esta semana también vimos como
el secretario de estado estadounidense
viajó a ria t Qué espera lograr Anthony
blinken de su visita a Arabia Saudita
pretende reparar sus lazos o
Yo creo que es un poco tarde no vemos
como Arabia Saudita ha crecido en margen
de autonomía pero a mí me parece que lo
que riad está diciendo no es que la
relación entre Estados Unidos y Arabia
Saudita se ha cancelado para siempre
sino que ha mutado ahora
qué está dispuesto a ofrecernos Estados
Unidos para afianzar nuestra relación de
una manera nos hemos vuelto mayores no
en esta relación queremos ser socios no
queremos ser más vistos en la región
como los alfiles de Estados Unidos
queremos tener una relación madura con
los Estados Unidos y me parece que
blinquen viene no de alguna manera a la
región va a la región justamente a ver
cómo puede comenzar a aceitar de una
mejor manera esta relación con una tarea
Saudita que me parece esta demostrando
una mayor madurez en temas diplomáticos
no
y también quería preguntarle también
tanto Irán como Arabia Saudita están
inmersos en el conflicto en yemen Cómo
pueden influir estas nuevas relaciones
en el conflicto en la guerra en yemen
que ya se prolonga durante casi una
década
sin dudas hay muy buenas proyecciones
para la cuestión femenina
no me animo a decir que la cuestión se
resuelva en el corto plazo estas
negociaciones suelen ser muy cerradas
pero la perspectiva para la cuestión
femenil me parece que es muy positiva
ahora que hay un contacto directo entre
las dos potencias que eran las que
estaban detrás de toda esta cuestión en
Géminis por supuesto sin negar las las
tensiones existentes al interior de
Jenny pero bueno puede ser que de alguna
manera se encause el conflicto Y
lleguemos a un acuerdo tentativo por lo
menos es ese al fuego me parece no
pues muchísimas gracias por este
análisis y por habernos acompañado en
France 24
y seguimos en Irán a Puerta cerrada y
sin permitirles hablar con sus abogados
así dio comienzo la primera vista del
juicio contra la periodista que reveló
el caso de la joven curto iraní
asesinada en septiembre Max examiní que
desató las protestas más masivas en Irán
en los últimos años y la condena
internacional ni lufa hamedy está
acusada por el régimen iraní de
colaborar con el gobierno hostil de
Estados Unidos colusión contra la
seguridad nacional y propaganda contra
el sistema lo que podría concluir con la
pena de muerte recordemos que casi un
centenar de periodistas y fotógrafos
fueron detenidos por realizar su trabajo
durante las protestas en Irán los grupos
de derechos humanos han denunciado las
condiciones del juicio Esto es lo que
dijo reporteros Sin fronteras
comienza a Puerta cerrada el juicio
contra ni lufar hamedy y el aje
mohamedhi las periodistas que alertaron
sobre el caso Masha mini afrontan pena
de muerte sin haber visto a sus ahogados
ni acceder al sumario denunciamos esta
injusticia falsa y exigimos su
Liberación son las séptimas elecciones
en poco menos de una década White votó
en medio de una crisis política
estancada que ha socavado el parlamento
y estancado la reformas Fiscales la
oposición retiene la mayoría del voto y
se hace con 29 de los 50 escaños en el
parlamento pero la participación
electoral fue más baja de lo habitual
solo el
51%, los comicios adelantados fueron
convocados después de que el tribunal
constitucional anulará en marzo los
resultados del año pasado este
estancamiento político ha llevado a una
precarización de los servicios sociales
como la educación o la sanidad pese a
ser uno de los países más enriquecidos
gracias a sus reservas de petróleo Esto
es lo que pedían los electores
queremos reformas queremos logros no
queremos oír palabras y discursos vacíos
queremos logros reales sobre el terreno
tenemos todas las capacidades para
convertirnos en el mejor país del Golfo
solo necesitamos estabilidad política y
reformas económicas para desarrollar
nuestro querido país
y a finales de mayo los residentes de la
comunidad Palestina de aensamilla en la
cisjordania ocupada se vieron forzados a
abandonar las tierras en las que
vivieron durante 40 años esto a raíz de
los constantes ataques de colonos
israelíes amparados por el ejército así
como las demoliciones y restricciones
las 178 personas pertenecientes a un
clan familiar de beduinos ahora se han
dispersado entre las colinas del área de
ramala sin acceso al agua y a las
tierras que tenían en su antiguo hogar
su subsistencia y como ganaderos y
agricultores se ve amenazada el líder de
esta comunidad Palestina nos cuenta en
primera persona cómo fue este
desplazamiento
Barcelona a nuestro
cinco años los colonos israelíes nos han
estado acosando traían sus propias
ovejas y no nos dejaban pastorear las
nuestras
teníamos un campo en el que plantábamos
trigo Pero ellos iban y o lo quemaban o
dejaban que sus ovejas comieran ahí
nuestros niños se sentían muy asustados
Porque casi cada noche los colonos
aparecían y tiraban piedras
la policía y el ejército lo suelen
proteger y cuando intentamos quejarnos
nos arrestan y nos tratan de mentirosos
como líder de la comunidad llegué a la
conclusión de que no podíamos esperar
más se volvió muy crítico y tenía que
pensar en las mujeres en los niños y no
podía ponerlos en riesgo Así que a fines
de mayo nos trasladamos aquí
esta tierra es de un agricultor que nos
está permitiendo quedarnos
en a insania había 37 familias casi 200
personas cuando decidimos mudarnos nos
dispersamos estamos repartidos porque
este lugar no puede albergarnos a todos
estas son nuestras cosas hay muebles
colchones sábanas están en el suelo
Porque no tenemos dónde ponerlas
se encuentra en el área sedes y Jordania
bajo control total israelí allí nuestra
escuela y nuestras tiendas se
enfrentaban órdenes de demolición donde
estamos ahora es el área B Así que
estamos más seguros
mantenemos entre 200 o 300 ovejas Pero
tenemos problemas para alimentarlas
porque el heno es muy costoso poco a
poco las estamos vendiendo para
sobrevivir
no podemos llevarlas a pastorear porque
las montañas como pueden ver son muy
áridas no hay nada para comer esto es
una gran pérdida porque Tendremos que
traerles comida extra
[Música]
no sabemos que nos va a deparar el
futuro porque tal vez el dueño de esta
tierra nos dice un día que ya es
suficiente y nos pide que nos vayamos
todo está en manos de Dios
[Música]
llegamos así al final de esta edición de
Expreso de oriente Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y los invito a enviar sus
comentarios a las redes sociales que
aparecen en sus pantallas y a seguir con
toda nuestra información en la página
web France 24.com
[Música]